here with more Trump attorney Joe
takapina we're talking a lot about
unequal justice under the law lack of
equal justice equal application if these
cases
are not related in so many they are
related in so many different ways nobody
wants to talk about it though Joe nobody
in the media wants to admit it they
don't even want to acknowledge that they
lie to the American people with
conspiracy theories for three years and
got away with it it's all like oh okay
we'll move on to the next thing
it's it's listen Sean what you just did
there that that little monologue and
that that series of Clips you put
together was so powerful it was a
powerful opening statement as to why
there at least should be parallel
investigations I mean they're spending
all this time millions of dollars
hundreds of prosecutors investigating
Donald Trump anything Donald Trump you
know find the Target and then go seek
the crime not the way it's supposed to
be in this country you have apparently
real evidence of Crimes by Joe Biden and
his son at least evidence that seems to
be worth an investigation and we can't
even get that here and that's what's so
sickening to the American people look it
is unconscionable for a president to
indict his leading political opponent
that's what the Biden justice department
just did
um you know Joe Biden kept classified
documents I mean the the honestly I
thought today they uncovered those
classified documents Joe Biden's garage
by his Corvette which looks like a pile
of garbage in an open area
um you know I thought that was the day
that there was no further
to do on the classified documents case
for president Trump because how could
they look so ridiculous to go and indict
president Trump for the same thing that
Joe Biden may have done and this is I
agree with Matt just said the law is on
President Trump's side here this is not
a case the Espionage Act does not rule
Supreme here and it's not going to apply
at the end of the day so but yeah
the the defense won't be able to bring
up will they how they treated Hillary or
how they treated job will they I doubt
it
well we'll be well the defense will
bring it up for sure in a motion to
dismiss this based on selective
prosecution that I will guarantee you
um that'll be brought up by you know the
Trump legal team for sure we will you
know file something that would show
there is a selective prosecution we made
here that's not before a jury of course
when we get to a jury the the different
question will be for for Todd and Chris
will be can they convince the jury that
the law is on President Trump's side
it's going to be important how obviously
the judge views that and what he
instructs the jury is the what the law
is
um but the law is on his side and what's
been done here is weaponization of our
justice system Sean this is a really
look we had this conversation a few
months ago when we were arraigned in
front of uh New York state court with
Alan Brandt's case a case that is in
shambles you know now here we are again
and it's they're not going to stop yet
things seem to be happening on the left
that you write gets a brush over a
complete brush over by the media and
it's really sickening it's it's a it's
hypocrite obviously and it's just it
really is a scary day for this country
because you heard president Trump he's
angry
um and it's the pendulum now going to
swing both ways is this the new Norm
where political opponents use their
justice department which is not really
Theirs to go after political opponents
all right Joe takapina we appreciate
your comments thanks for being with us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else